also a big scare here at home after  reports of a student with a gun on the  southeast career technical academy  campus police say those reports were  unfounded but the campus was placed on  lockdown for some time and dozens of  parents showed up there in search of  answers many of them concerned about  their kids after the situation in texas  i was thinking that but i also knew  rumors were flying through the text and  and everything from gunshots to a bomb  too and i said it you know just kept her  calm and and when she said someone said  they heard gunshots i'm like did you she  said no then it didn't happen  police tell us they are investigating  where these reports and texts originated  from